when Jackie Bell trowel sets they
brought your tailors coming into the
studio I thought she meant the tennis
player the legendary English tennis but
no word is it is the the guy the one who
was the drummer from Queen very good to
see you Ron so still in search and still
is that's true we're gonna get on to
that but also he's like there is doing
things on his own this is your first new
solo album in many years for many yeah
many years it's taken me about five
years to make it so each stretch fairly
different and which i think is a good
thing yeah yeah well we the album's
called fun on earth and from that album
here is sunny day
what do you like doing doing bass tronto
the drumming or the singing
I think the singing is more satisfying
in a way yes because especially if
you've written the song but drumming's
my sort of real trade you know and I've
always done both so I've had a lot of
people come up to me after 40 odd years
with Queen and say oh you sing I said we
will revise there were three singers you
know but Freddie was our lead singer my
life has been ruined by drumming my son
is 11 years of age I could say the same
what I never got was with most
instruments she can hear a tune or
whatever but he just goes into that room
and bangs bangs bangs bangs bangs bangs
he's I'm told he's very good at it he
gets certificates for doing it but it's
driving me up the wall you have to do it
in conjunction with other people really
to understand what you do otherwise you
know he's probably got all the
instruments in his head you know hang on
but I mean I think I drove my neighbours
fairly mad when I was a kid in it by
drumming in the garage yeah it's a noise
instrument yeah but it is a real musical
instrument contrary to what some people
would say I know right
no I Nazanin we should point out big
Queen fan yeah yes indeed and arch I was
gonna ask you has your son that features
at all many of the album because your
son Rufus and when I went to see you in
Hammersmith last year wasn't staged with
you and he's very Musical and stuff so I
wanted that's right now he did actually
co-write what and one of those songs
with me but he wrote this piano piece
it's called be with you and I thought
they were great chords so I wrote the
song around that and he's playing piano
and not drums people don't know actually
that you have actually had a lot of solo
albums since Queen just this is the
fifth were match near and you know it's
just something I do when we're not
working with green and to express myself
how'd you got run out of ideas isn't
there a point we think you know what I
can't do this anymore after I've written
all my ideas down before they've all
been done I'm gonna I'm gonna swallow
I do sometimes right now have ideas but
you just wait for the next one
just pops into your head after all these
years you know you need it so that keeps
doing is what we do we do
well these this queen extravaganza
there's lots of those coming along a lot
of UK tour tour dates taking you up
until well to 12 12 foot vendor member
and Bristol I think that's yeah wait
were you finished and but we want to
show people more a glimpse of what it's
like and this is Bohemian Rhapsody and
this is from the guy will show you
Freddie Merrick mercury and we're gonna
shoot Freddie first or second first
right this is Freddie this is how you
will know Freddie doing Bohemian
Rhapsody first of all then we're going
to show you the Queen extravaganza guy
who's called Mark Martel doing the same
thing here we go
tell you what he's got a harbor's he's
got a tough act to follow but he's got a
lot of Freddie characteristics there
hasn't he yes extraordinary we were very
lucky to find him vocally he if you
close your eyes you would swear mmm that
Freddie was in the room and that's the
thing at events like that people want to
suspend belief don't do they want to
believe that that queen is back and
everything's as it was well I don't know
I'm not trying to sort of really treat
reality but um I just think so here our
music played beautifully and brilliantly
and and you've got a man who just by
sheer chance sounds exactly like Freddie
I think we were very lucky seeing the
new film that's in the early stages
isn't it about Freddie yeah do you like
to see play Freddie Dennis Cooper talk
have been with Shaw yeah I mean I think
Ben Whishaw was a fabulous actor but
it's not really in my hands and so I
think involved you think yeah oh we're
definitely Brian and I are doing the
music for the movie but making movies
seems to be like swimming in treacle
it's it's not a fast process but some
yeah yeah I think we would like him but
I don't think it's all signed and sealed
and delivered his Ben was sure he is the
one he was in the latest Bond film and
also he's in that drama the hour as well
well Roger thanks for coming in and
thank you to all your groupies who are
with you here on this couch nice very
nice isn't it it's very cool see thank
thanks thanks Nick it make yourself at
home and the Queen extravaganza the UK
tour dates there right through till the
the 12th of November and they finish
Manchester and then Bristol